- Your hunger will drive you every day.
- Hunger.
- The main thing, hunger.
- Hungry.
- Hello, Believe Nation.
Today we're going to talk
about how you can be hungry.
And as always, guys, as
you're watching the videos,
if you see something that really resonates
with you, please leave
it in the comments below.
And put quotes around it, so other people
can be inspired.
And if you write it down,
it's much more likely to
stick with yourself, as well.
(upbeat music)
- When you think about life,
everybody wants the prize,
but nobody wants the process.
Everybody wants the championship
but nobody wants the day to day.
Everybody wants to win games.
But nobody wants to put in the work
that it takes to win games.
In the Bible, it talks about in Proverbs,
it says, "The laborer's
appetite works for him.
"And his hunger drives him on.
"The laborer's appetite works for him.
"And his hunger drives him on."
And so my question to you all is,
"What's your appetite for winning?"
Because if you have a
appetite for winning,
your hunger will drive you, every day.
Your hunger will take
you to the weight room.
Your hunger will take you past 32.
Your hunger will take
you past the opposition.
Your hunger will take you past adversity.
Your hunger will take you past
the trials and tribulations.
Your hunger will take you
to that fourth quarter
when there's four zeros on that clock.
You have emptied that bucket,
you have given everything
you had, in that game.
See, it's a certain mindset
man, when you attack this thing.
The game of football,
it's not about skill.
That's what people miss the boat on.
This game is not about, it
has nothing to do with skill.
It has nothing to do with a 40 yard pass.
It has nothing to do with
jumping a 40 inch vertical.
What this game is about, it's about will.
That's it.
It's not about skill,
this game is about will.
And so, the moment that
you make up in your mind.
The day that you make up in your mind,
that you are going to
play this game for God
and give everything you got to it.
You can't help, but to
give everything you got.
And that's the moment that you'll realize
this game has nothing to do with skill.
I seen plenty of talented guys fold.
I seen plenty of talented
guys get hit in the mouth,
and they did't want it.
I seen plenty of talented guys get punched
in the face and they
go back to the sideline
and they stand beside they coach.
And they don't want it no more.
They make up excuses.
I seen plenty of talented guys.
They ran a four in 240 and
bench press 325 pounds.
When third and one came up,
they tapped they helmet
to come out of the game.
That has nothing to do with skill.
- Ask yourself, "What
if no one ever bought
"any of my work?
"What if I'm never going to sell a book,
"or publish a book, or a short story?"
Are you going to continue to write?
And if the answer is,
"Yes, because I have to."
then yeah, you are a writer.
And whether you'll sell
or not I can't know,
but if there's stories in
you that have to get out,
and you want to put
them down on the paper,
whether you ever get the
affirmation of a contract,
or a book in your hand,
or being on the best seller list.
If you still have to tell your stories
then you're a writer.
If you can give it up, then probably
it would be an act of
sanity to learn accounting
or something like that.
- How much further can you go?
- That's a really good question.
And I don't know the answer to that.
I don't have those types of goals, of,
"I want this number."
I just have the goal
of, "I want to play well
"at this tournament.
"I want to win this tournament.
"And then I want to win this tournament."
And when I wake up one morning
and just, absolutely, do
not want to go on the court.
Or have no motivation to go on the court,
then that's when it'll be, good for me.
- Has acting turned out to be
all that you wanted it to be?
- It's incredible.
You know, I never knew that
I could do it as a career.
It was the first memory that I had.
The first thing I could
think of is saying,
"I want to be an actor, to my parents."
And if I hadn't lived in Los Angeles
and been in such close proximity,
to, sort of, the mecca of movie making,
if I didn't have parents that said,
"Okay, we'll drive you to auditions."
We didn't have the economic means
to move camp from Idaho to Los Angeles
because some snotty, 10 year old kid says,
"I want to be an actor."
(laughs)
We did it, after school
I got to go on auditions,
but it was always, and
I've said this before,
it felt like an elite group of people.
And it felt like I would
never belong to them.
So once I got the
opportunity to, for example,
get the movie, This Boy's Life,
with Robert DeNiro, I said,
"Wow, I might be able to
steer the course of my career.
"I might be able to have a career,
"similar to these guys that I so admire."
And that, I knew at 15 years old,
was the biggest gift in the world.
And that's never left me.
That thirst or that hunger, for wanting
to give one great performance
that I am truly satisfied with.
Or be in one movie, that I said,
"I love this film," is something
that I don't know will ever be quenched.
I don't know.
And I think that's a good thing.
Because it keeps pushing you, you know?
Constantly dissatisfied, in other words.
- Paul Newman told me,
that any successful person,
in any field, who in
discussing their career,
doesn't use the word, luck, is a liar.
- Oh yeah, he's absolutely right.
- So you consider yourself lucky.
- Very lucky, yeah.
- But you have to have talent,
to meet the luck, right?
- Somebody hands you the ball and you run.
And if you get hit, you get hit.
Or maybe you make it through.
You never know.
But I just know that
somebody handed me the ball,
at a certain point,
and I was hungry enough
to keep running.
And I'm still running.
I've maintained a hunger,
but not an ambition.
I'm very happy to
explore all possibilities
of the character.
And really dive in
to the role.
I mean, to the point of where
Disney wanted to fire me.
- They wanted to fire you from, Pirates?
- Yeah.
- Because?
- They couldn't understand
what I was doing.
And they didn't understand the character.
They actually were contemplating
subtitling the film.
(laughs)
- I mean, success, I
don't think it's something
you can, I don't think
you can describe success.
Because it means different
things to different people.
And there's different levels of success.
I'd say we're starting
to enjoy success now.
I bought my mom a brand
new car for her birthday.
That was definitely a
dream come true, for me.
That was a level of success.
But then you look at Jay Z,
you know what I'm saying?
He'll tell you a billion is success.
When he makes it to a B, or whatever,
you know what I'm saying?
He's way, way, way up
there in the stratosphere.
So, that's just, like, I
don't tell myself I made it.
I don't tell myself I'm successful.
I tell myself, I'm hungry.
And I want to keep going.
- I didn't have an easy experience.
I didn't come in as a top rated recruit.
I didn't come in with the opportunity
to play right away.
I had to earn it.
And you know what the greatest honor
I've ever received, as a player is?
In my fourth year and my fifth year,
I was named team captain.
That, to this day, is the single,
greatest achievement I've
ever had as a football player.
Because the men in this room
chose me to lead their team.
And these were my best friends.
These were the guys that
knew that I liked to work.
That knew that I loved football.
That knew that I loved to play.
That knew that I wanted to be
the quarterback for Michigan.
And all the lessons that I learnt here
on State Street, and in the big house.
That's still what I
bring to practice today.
And after 14 years, I love the game
more than I've ever loved it.
- Oh, it was historical.
I was thinking about
that run all the time.
Oklahoma City is all about, first off,
natural disasters, and
Oklahoma City bombing.
Just to put it out there, to be real.
That's what this city was known for.
And to win, a Western
Conference Championship
with a group of young guys,
in a city that's never
seen anything like it,
that's something I'm
always going to remember.
- [Announcer] But the
Thunder, lost the NBA title
to the Miami Heat and
LeBron James in five games.
Kevin Durant was second, again.
And there to console
him was the same person
who made him do pushups,
in the middle of the night,
12 years earlier.
- [Interviewer] A long hug
with your mom, after you all
didn't make it there.
You hugged her long and hard.
- Well first off, that
was just like a thank you.
My mom, she was always there
at the right time, man.
And a lot of people got on me for crying
on national TV.
But, when you wanted something that bad,
it was just like, I didn't care.
- I do everything.
I love jet skiing,
going out on club bikes,
motorbikes, surfing, rock climbing,
pretty much anything with an engine.
Yeah, I try to do as many things as I can.
I love to do water skiing.
I like to do wakeboarding
and water skiing.
I pretty much do quite a few things,
but those are the things I do to,
My dad will be like,
"You shouldn't be doing
"any of those things.
"Because you race a Formula One car,
"you don't need it."
But when you're not
racing, you need something
to keep that adrenaline
and that hunger going.
- [Man] Get the plague and
the people holding the plaque.
- [Young Man] Bad boy, represent.
- [Man] Get the plaque.
Couple of times, on the plaque, aight.
- We just going to keep trying
to feed our families, yo.
You know what I'm saying?
It's a job.
It ain't nothing where somebody just felt
like doing it and they did it,
you know what I'm saying?
We was hungry.
Everybody got to eat,
know what I'm saying?
I found something I was good at.
I'm just trying to flip it, yo.
Keep it going, you know what I'm saying?
I ain't trying to slack at all.
I'm a throw this out to my peoples,
my borough, and my family, and on my eye.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I hope you enjoyed.
I'd love to know which of the clips
had the biggest impact on you and why.
Leave it down in the comments.
I'm going to join in the discussion.
I also want to know, how
are you being hungry?
What do you do in your business,
in your life, right now to stay hungry?
Leave it down in the comments.
I also want to give a quick shout out
to Charli Funk.
Thank you Charli for picking up a copy
of my book, Your One Word,
and sending that Tweet out about it.
I really, really, really appreciate it.
So thank you guys, again, for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.